[Music]
and good evening to you thank you for
joining us at five we do start with a
developing story out of pahrump i'm
kirstjen joyce
and i'm denise valdez brian is off
tonight so this is a story with a lot of
twists and turns that
tonight a suspected kidnappers though
are in custody
more details we're learning here at five
just hours ago 49 year old
keith holman and 36 year old kristen
faff of parump
were arrested in henderson now according
to the nye county sheriff's office the
victim
was held in a paround building and was
rescued just on new year's day
joe muller spoke to neighbors who are
still in shock that something like this
was happening right down the street
joe
we are waiting to get some more
information regarding this arrest but we
do know it was tips from the public that
put these two behind bars here in
henderson earlier today we did go out to
parump and we spoke to several people
who live in that area
where that woman was rescued from and
they were all pretty surprised by this
story
according to the nye county sheriff's
office the woman was held for months and
forced to do manual labor
the victim was allegedly kidnapped in
march of last year and brought to the
building you're seeing in this video
with barred windows and barricades at
the front door
the building also has cameras and motion
sensors police found out about her
location after her mother got a facebook
message from the victim
now people who live near this location
say it is disturbing to hear this
happening for so long
can't even conceive it it's unbelievable
i'm pretty shocked it's it's not
something that
that you hear about in our community
this is not the first time this couple
has had a run-in with the law exactly
three years ago from today's arrest they
were arrested in a case involving
starving an animal the sheriff's office
reports keith holman sexually assaulted
the victim back in 2018
both are facing a number of charges
including second degree kidnapping
and false imprisonment now this couple
is expected to be transported to the nye
county detention center
here very soon reporting live in
henderson joe mullen 8 news now